in today's video we're going to be
focusing on a few altcoins five in
particular which broke their macro
downtrends and why is this important
because when price breaks a macro
downtrend dating back all the way to
2021 breaking a macro downtrend means
that price then enters a new macro
uptrend lasting for a similar amount of
time so if it's been over 2 years since
that time or two years since we've
broken the macro downtrend the macro
uptrend could then now last up to 2
years as well so in today's video we're
going to be talking about five altcoins
subscribe to the channel for more videos
like this in the future like this video
if you enjoy videos like this going
forward and let's dive right into it
because the first altcoin we're going to
be talking about is salana salana has
broken its macro downtrend and the way
it broke its macro downtrend was by
forming a reaccumulation range at highs
breaking this macro downtrend and then
pulling back was part of the retesting
price action not actually retesting ing
this level as a new support but
maintaining this reaccumulation range
before breaking and resuming its micro
up Trend generally speaking we can
expect new alltime highs for salana and
over time that should be the case a new
macro uptrend has occurred and it's only
been a few months that salana is
enjoying a macro uptrend but it's going
to be enjoying it for a few months more
several months more in in fact up to
2025 most likely when a macro downtrend
like this breaks a new macro uptrend
occurs and that's salana altcoin number
one allcoin number two that broke its
macro downtrend as well is avax
Avalanche and it's broken its downtrend
already breaking out from this macro
Market structure right over here any
retesting of the top of this structure
would be a great opportunity for me
personally to be reaccumulated here but
generally speaking it's broken one macro
downtrend meaning that it's escaped this
consolidation period within this Major
Market structure it's now no longer
consolidating within this structure it's
ready for a new trend and that new trend
is a macro uptrend and so price is going
to revisit this downtrend so avax still
has a macro downtrend to break but it'll
probably comfortably break Beyond here
as well because when price breaks a
macro downtrend the first one the second
one is also probably going to break with
time over time and that's coin number
two altcoin number three is Matic
polygon here it's forming a major Market
structure where we're seeing price try
to break Beyond here important that we
don't upside Wick Beyond here so it's
still in the balance whether polygon is
going to break out from this macro
Market Market structure on the weekly
time frame it's already retesting the
top of this structure as a new support
if we do zoom in here you'll see that
that retest is in progress but a monthly
candle close above here would change the
trend because in the past we've upside
Wicked Beyond this macro downtrend we've
upside Wicked Beyond this macro
downtrend we've also done the same here
now but if we monthly close here then
that would mean that price is no longer
upside wicking and getting sold into
we're actually going to see maintaining
of strength if we get that monthly close
here and that would mean the end of the
macro downtrend and when a macro
downtrend breaks a new macro uptrend
occurs and so Matic polygon is getting
ready for a new macro uptrend it just
needs to monthly close here potentially
even dip into this top of the major
Market structure to claim it as a new
support so that that springboards price
into the psychological region of $1
roughly speaking this blue level because
rallying into here and reclaiming this
level as a new support in the past that
has really done well for price when
we've retested this for instance we've
seen a rally to new alltime highs back
in the day as well failing to keep this
level as a support has proceeded
downside however so retesting this top
of the structure would enable a rally to
the blue level and reclaiming this level
is quite important to Rally even higher
and break back into this wide range
where there is a volume Gap where lots
of volatility occurs when prices inside
this range we see lot of volatility
occur and strong price moves towards the
upside and this time would be no
different once Matic polygon is able to
break into that region but that's
altcoin number three and number four
here is Po up and if you look at these
two structures they're very very similar
falling wedges downtrending channels
Major Market structures that have lasted
a very long time and poka dot here is
doing a little bit better than Matic
polygon polygon is just below here
trying to retest this on the weekly time
frame here poka is ready to monthly
close above the top of this Market
structure potentially pull back for
retest of the top of this pattern before
rallying into this red region of
resistance and just notice what a key
reference point for Price this is for
polygon because we've seen a rejection
in the previous bull market and then
rally retest with this downside Wick
before rallying to new alltime highs
here in the bare Market we saw price
successfully retest and hold here for a
limited time before breaking down upside
Wick to fail to break Beyond this macro
downtrend but generally speaking
reclaiming this
region as a new support in the same way
that we saw in
2021 that would enable an explosive
rally and one of the major resistances
for pokera in this new macro uptrend
that's potentially geing up for this is
the next major resistance era and you'll
notice that this chart resembles
bitcoin's chart in a lot of ways and
Bitcoin has actually Revisited its
analogous level right over here the
analogous level Bitcoin is around 35k
here and you can just see how polka dot
is simply lagging and so polka Do's aim
is generally and so is the aim of many
altcoins to catch up to bitcoin and
rally towards its next level which is
analogous to bitcoin at this moment in
the cycle with Bitcoin now at 35k at
this point in the video at this time
risting this region of around $18 $166
$17 that that's where polka do would
only just catch up to bitcoin and when
Bitcoin continues its rally to new highs
polka do will need to even catch up even
further and could rally even higher than
that but this is the next major
resistance for polka monthly close here
and it sets off a new Macro uptrend for
this coin breaking out from this macro
Market structure that price has been in
since mid 2022 so over a year and a half
now so pooda on the cusp of a new macro
uptrend in the same way that we're
seeing link chain link break its macro
downtrend as well it's only just broken
it this month and so the key thing for
chain link is to retest this macro
downtrend if at all we get a dip or to
reclaim this red resistance area as a
new support because that would enable
this screen pass to new Highs but
generally
speaking this macro downtrend is over
for chain link and you can see here
upside Wick and upside Wicks Beyond this
macro downtrend now we're actually
getting a full bodied candle and so the
trend shift is very clear here chain
link broke out from a 500 day plus
accumulation range at the bare Market
lows and broke out very quickly and in
just two months it's broken its last
major monthly macro downtrending
resistance and it could retest it in the
short term but overall all chain link is
ready for a new macro uptrend that will
take it to New alltime highs with time
in this new bull market thank you so
much for watching subscribe to the
channel for more videos like this in the
future like this video if you enjoy
content like this going forward I'm re
Capital thanks so much for watching
check out the top right hand corner
video for more and I'll speak to you in
the next one speak too soon